[Music]  I'm Rick Dalton it's my pleasure mr.  Schwartz ugly mouth put it down  that's your son no that's my stunt  double cliff booth hey Rick Dalton  double feature I love that stuff you're  told that killing a lot of killing  [Music]  seems this  [Music]  you still direct bill here you could do  anything you want  I hired you to be an actor wick not a TV  cowboy you're better than that  line all right what's matter partner  it's official old buddy has been Here I  am flat on my ass I got a little next  door to me I'm Sharon Tate I'm in the  movie you're in this that's me I claim  these Karlsson the class  [Music]  Charlie's gonna take him  [Music]  [Music]  in this town I can all change like that  hey you're Rick [ __ ] Dalton don't you  forget it  [Music]  you